[Musik]
tf heute live herzlich willkommen eine
schicksalswahl für europa ist das wenn
frankreich am sonntag über seinen
präsidenten abstimmt oder seine
präsidentin denn noch nie war die
wahrscheinlichkeit so hoch dass die
rechtsextremisten marin lippen gewinnen
könnte was würde ihr sieg für europa
bedeuten und warum können sich so viele
unserer französischen nachbarn offenbar
vorstellen lücken zu wählen darüber
sprechen wir heute in der sendung wie
immer sehr gerne mit ihnen und euch die
kommentare oder fragen bitte in die
kommentare oder per e mail an zdf
heute.de
zdf.de und thomas walde fast uns vorab
zusammen wo frankreich denn steht zwei
tage vor der wahl
zum ende teilt emanuel makro noch einmal
richtig aus ein lockerer auftritt in der
banlieue von paris an dem sozialen
brennpunkt der mehrheitlich links führte
hier leben viele menschen die man kaum
bisher nicht überzeugen konnte makro
will mobilisieren durch die scharfe
abgrenzung zu seiner konkurrentin
dürfen wir dürfen uns nicht an den
aufstieg extrem rechter ideen gewöhnen
es gibt unterschiede innerhalb der
demokratischen debatte die sich im
lokalen oder landesweiten wahlen
ausdrücken aber daneben gibt es
grundsätzliche unterschiede in werten
auch martin le pen betont zum abschluss
des wahlkampfes fundamentale
unterschiede lange hatte sie versucht
sich im wahlkampf gemäßigt und präsidial
zu zeigen vor anhängern viel sie jetzt
in alte rechtspopulistische muster
zurück folgt frankreichs steht auf gegen
jene die so wenig achtung für die
verteidigung unserer zivilisation haben
die deine geschichte in den dreck ziehen
seine kultur seine traditionen die deine
demografische zukunft der emigration
unterwerfen die die errichtung großer
moscheen erlauben unterschiedlichem
fremden einfluss
[Musik]
le pen bekräftigte zuletzt auch ihre
ankündigung im fall ihrer wahl das
kopftuch in der öffentlichkeit zu
verbieten frankreich ist das land in
europa mit dem größten anteil von
muslimen
das ist gefährlich das ist ein angriff
auf die persönlichkeit auf den
persönlichen glauben
man will etwas politisieren was nicht
politisch sondern sehr persönlich ist
eine sehr persönliche entscheidung
so hat frankreich am sonntag die wahl
zwischen zwei diametral
entgegengesetzten politischen und
gesellschaftlichen entwürfen seiner
zukunft
darüber sprechen wir mit christel haas
unserer zdf korrespondentin in paris
christel ich sehe hier schon im chat
schreibt zum beispiel thomas rabenstein
über youtube falls frankreich an die
rechtsnationale lippen geht brechen
dunkle zeiten für die eu die nato und
das deutsch-französische verhältnis
herein wer zittert alles mit mir das ist
natürlich auch ein großer grund warum
wir diesen stream machen für die
zuschauer in deutschland denn das ist
das was die leute hier umtreibt wie sind
denn die zahlen aktuell wir sind dann
die letzten umfragen
na ja die letzten umfragen ist gerade
eine neue herausgekommen die seen schon
einen vorsprung firma krone liegt jetzt
in den umfragen bei 57 prozent marine le
pen bei 43 aber es sind halt eben nur um
fragen und wichtig ist auch dass viele
einfach noch unentschieden sind und es
kommt jetzt darauf an wie wählen die die
im ersten wahlgang andere kandidaten
gewählt haben die nicht in die stichwahl
gekommen sind und da ist es so dass
diejenigen die grünen gewählt haben den
grünen-kandidaten doch gut die hälfte
mikrowellen wollen und die den
linksaußen männer schon gewählt haben
die wollen zumindest ich hab's mir
aufgeschrieben zu 34%
mikrowellen aber es sind eben auch
immerhin 17 oder 18 prozent für le pen
dabei und da sind daneben auch noch
viele die nicht entschieden sind und
viele wollen vielleicht auch gar nicht
zur wahl gehen von diesen vor allen
dingen von diesen links wählern oder an
ungültigen wahlzettel abgeben und darf
diese stimmen kommt es an auf diese
stimme ist auch makro angewiesen mit
welchen themen haben die beiden denn
besonders gepunktet fangen wir mal an
mit der herausforderin mitten marin
lippen
ja sie hat jetzt also ist heute der
letzte tag des wahlkampfs beide haben
jetzt nochmal auftritte gemacht dass sie
sind in orte gefahren um nochmal für ihr
programm zu werben und da würde auch
ganz deutlich wie groß die kluft
zwischen den beiden ist marine le pen
hat in ihrem da wo sie war sie war im
norden unterwegs das ist so ein bisschen
eine hochburg von ihr wo viele für sie
gestimmt haben und er hat sie eindeutig
gesagt es ist die wahl zwischen makro
und frankreich also sie hat ganz genau
polarisiert immer nur froh ist im süden
und versucht natürlich da auch die
wähler noch umzustimmen die
unentschieden sind marine le pen hat vor
allem damit gepunktet dass sie sich als
anwältin der kleinen der sogenannten
kleinen leute gut inszeniert hat sie
nimmt die sorgen ernst sie hat sich
wirklich gezeigt dass sie nah an den
leuten ist die nicht soviel geld haben
und deswegen war eines ihrer hauptthemen
auch das thema kaufkraft das in
frankreich wirklich ein großes sorgen
thema es denn es gibt eben doch sehr
viele menschen die sorgen haben am ende
des monats nicht mit ihrem geld
auskommen zu können und alles ist teurer
geworden dass benzin die preise sind
angestiegen auch in der folge des
ukraine kriegs und genau diese menschen
sind unzufrieden mit makro und
unzufrieden mit ihrem leben sie wollen
veränderungen und die hat marine le pen
hier abgeholt und das sind vor allem die
treuen marine le pen wähler außerdem ist
natürlich eines ihrer großen themen die
im wahlkampf so ein bisschen weich
gespült worden sind nicht ganz so
diesmal so stark gezeigt wurden das ist
die emigration die migration marine le
pen hat zu einer art fremdenfeindliche
politik sie wieder ein referendum wenn
sie gewählt wird ein referendum abhalten
über ihre immigrationspolitik sie möchte
dass die franzosen
bevorzugt werden was die wohnungssuche
was die arbeitsplatzsuche anbelangt und
sie möchte einfach die immigration stark
einschränken viele leute ausweisen und
vor allen dingen auch das kopftuch
verbieten damit hat sie natürlich auch
bei vielen franzosen gepunktet dann
kommen wir zum amtsinhaber im manuellen
makro womit hat er versucht die leute
für sich zu gewinnen
na ja er hat natürlich eine bilanz zu
verteidigen die hatte verteidigt und da
gibt es auch gute dinge darin er hat die
arbeitslosigkeit gesenkt er hat die
wirtschaft ist relativ gut trotz corona
und das sind eben schon auch seine
erfolge und er ist natürlich auch im
internationalen bereich sehr angesehen
und kann als staatsmann auftreten und
wird er sehr ernst genommen das kommt
natürlich auch in frankreich gut an und
damit hat er nun eben auch versucht zu
punkten sein thema ist tatsächlich
europa und er hat heute auch noch mal
gesagt diese wahl ist ein referendum für
oder gegen europa das ist so das große
ziel das er hat er will versuchen
natürlich auch die kaufkraft zu stärken
das hat ist ihm so ein bisschen auch die
füße gefallen im wahlkampf weil das
nicht so oder das große thema war und er
will jetzt eben auch versuchen durch
prämien durch lebensmittel sex einfach
gekauft auf der franzosen anzuheben und
auch damit versucht zu punkten und 1
letzter 1 letztes thema das er auch
relativ spät im wahlkampf noch
eingebracht hat ist das klima da setzt
er natürlich auf den ausbau von den
erneuerbaren energien aber eben auch auf
die atomkraft aber das ist auch eines
seiner großen ziele
christel ich sehe hier ein kommentar von
einem user oder einer userin namens
princess die schreibt bin kein fan von
makro- und seinen versprechungen wie
wäre es aber trotzdem lieber dass er
wieder präsident wird als sie das ist
also die meinung dieser userin oder
dieses users wenn man sich aber die die
haltung vieler franzosen anguckt die
sind ja sehr reserviert ihrem
präsidenten gegenüber viele wir schauen
uns mal dass instagram profil an
sagen wir mal haus und hoffotograf in
von im manuellen makro wir sehen hier
auf dem monitor das ist ihr profil und
wir gehen mal in den letzten post das
ist vor fünf tagen gewesen da hat sie
ihn begleitet auf einer wahlkampftour
wir sehen makro wie er sich
das t-shirt auszieht und das hemd
anzieht wir sehen missio präsident wir
sehen einen dynamischen emanuel makro
wir die bühne erobert und hier auf
diesem foto die herzen der der zuschauer
gewinnt wir sind einen wegweisenden
makro hier noch mal sehr dynamisch und
dann christel sehen wir dieses foto
wir sehen den präsidenten sehr legere
und aufgeknöpft auf einer ledercouch
liebe christel und abgesehen von der
frage ob das brusthaar jetzt echt ist
oder nicht was genau mögen die franzosen
an diesem präsidenten und was mögen sie
nicht wofür stehen diese bilder
also ob das brust da echt ist oder nicht
das kann ich leider auch nicht sagen ich
weiß es nicht diese bilder sollen
natürlich das dynamische image eines
jungen präsidenten makros er der jüngste
präsident
frankreichs er war 39 als er das amt
angetreten hat man will das natürlich
fördern man möchte zeigen er hat dynamik
hat ausstrahlung ist bereit was zu
machen das hemmt bedeutet ich bin nicht
immer nur im anzug unterwegs sondern
wenn ich mich warm geredet habe dann
muss ich dann auch mal meine jacke wenn
man sakko ausziehen und dann krempelt er
die ärmel hoch und dann fange ich auch
an zu arbeiten und ich mache auch was
ich tue was das ist das ziel dieser
kampagne warum viele franzosen mit makro
nicht einverstanden sind in teilweise
regelrecht hassen das liegt an mehreren
dingen es von beruf oder er war banker
und das hat in frankreich einen ganz
schlechten ruf also wenn man bei einer
bank gearbeitet hat dann ist man schon
von grund auf schon mal kein guter
mensch weil man mit geld umgeht weil man
mit geld handelt möglicherweise auch
viel geld hat und das wird in nicht so
gerne gesehen das ist das eine das
andere ist es wird ihm vorgeworfen sehr
arrogant und herablassend zu sein und
das ist er manchmal auch er hat dann
einfach sich so ein paar schnitzer
geleistet die bei den franzosen nicht so
gut ankamen zum beispiel dass er einem
arbeitslosen bei als er in paris
unterwegs war der ihn angesprochen hat
dass er keine arbeit findet dann hat er
dann geantwortet na ja sie müssen nur
über die straße gehen da finden sie
schon ganz leichten job das kam bei den
franzosen nicht gut an und er hat auch
mal geredet von den niemanden also die
leute die nichts sind und das ist eben
genau bei denen menschen die wenig geld
haben die die ringen müssen um über die
runden zu kommen das ist ein bisschen im
hals stecken geblieben und es gab
natürlich auch die geld westen die ihm
genau das vorgeworfen dass er alles
verteuert und dass er eben überhaupt
nicht auf das volk hört und das alles
zusammen genommen und er ist auch sehr
liberal und er ist in manchen augen auch
wenig grün zu wenig sozial zu wenig in
kontakt mit den menschen und das alles
hat dazu geführt dass viele ihn einfach
nicht mögen damit ist vielleicht auch
die frage von karin will auf facebook
beantwortet woran liegt es denn dass
marco die ärmeren leute nicht erreicht
oder kann man das noch ein bisschen
detaillierter beantworten die frage
na ja
er hat schon versucht auf die leute
zuzugehen das erstaunliche ist ja wenn
marco in der straße ist wenn er einen
besuch macht wenn er in einer ortschaft
geht oder eine stadt dann nimmt das sich
zeit für die leute und er argumentiert
auch erhört die hinzu und versucht
einfach auch die leute zu überzeugen und
er geht nicht einfach weiter wenn die
unangenehme frage gestellt wird also er
kann mit den menschen schon sehr gut es
ist aber auch ein unterschied in der
haltung oder in der sprache er ist ist
natürlich sehr intellektuell erdrückt
sich sehr geschliffen aus er spricht
dann von schulden
ein dämmungen und schuldenrückzahlung
und das verstehen viele einfach nicht er
spricht eben nicht ihre sprache und das
ist der vorteil von marine le pen die
sich eben tatsächlich sehr einfach
ausdrückt und damit eben auch auf großes
verständnis der etwas
einkommensschwächeren schichten stößt
hier schreibt magnus auch über youtube
seine meinung macros elitär und arrogant
ohne ende die französische revolution
hätte er nicht überlebt schreibt dieser
user mit dem blick mit seinem eigenen
blick in die geschichte
christel wir sehen auch hier im chat
dass viele tatsächlich die frage auch
umtreibt welche auswirkungen die wahl
von le pen auf den krieg in der ukraine
hätte zb vassili zaitsev schreibt das
über youtube und ich würde gerne mit
ihnen und euch zusammen einmal auf einen
tweet gucken
unser korrespondent in brüssel florian
hahn hat retweetet von alexei navalny
diese der harten langen brett gepostet
und florian hat es eben retweetet mit
der frage oder mit der aussage wenn
russlands berühmtester politischer
häftling navalny einen flammenden appell
schreibt an die wähler in frankreich und
sie bittet nicht die putin freundin
marie le pen zu wählen wir sehen also
navalny hat sich geäußert hat die
franzosen aufgerufen nicht le pen zu
wählen wie ist das in frankreich
aufgenommen worden welche rolle spielt
das
also zuerst muss man sagen dass auch
marine le pen es war spät aber dennoch
den ukraine krieg verurteilt hat sie hat
natürlich eine gute beziehung zu kitten
und hat auch gesagt naja wenn dann
irgendwann mal frieden ist dann möchte
ich eine bevorzugte partnerschaft mit
russland und mit putin eingehen das
thema putin war am anfang schon spielte
schon eine rolle das ist ein bisschen
untergegangen weil die wähler von marine
le pen das muss man wissen die sind ja
auch euro skeptisch die wollen raus aus
der aus der eu die finden die ganz
furchtbar die globalisierung
verstehen die welt nicht mehr und sie
haben das gefühl dass ihnen viele
entscheidungen abgenommen werden von
diesem koloss eu deswegen hat es
eigentlich gar keinen großen keine große
kritik hervorgerufen weil weil sie
einfach sagen naja dann gehen wir raus
aus der eu oder wir machen das anders es
wird eine ein staatenbund der nationen
das finden wir gut dann sind wir wieder
die die franzosen können alleine
entscheiden und es ist auch nicht so
groß diskutiert worden das marine le pen
eben diese engen kontakte zu putin hat
oder auch sucht das sie natürlich auch
die kontakte zu anderen
rechtspopulistischen regierungschefs in
der eu sucht das ist hier nicht so
thematisiert worden weil es wegen eben
diesen diese große kluft gibt zwischen
denen die europa verteidigen und denen
die eben europa skeptisch sind und da
spielt auch der ukraine krieg und putin
eine rolle
christel noch eine frage zum
abschlussbericht ist ja auch schon sehr
lange aus paris wie wie funktioniert
denn eure berichterstattung aus dem
élysée-palast wien aber ist denn der der
präsident wie funktioniert die
pressearbeit und wie habt ihr da die
letzten wochen so so begleiten können
eigentlich
also die letzten woche vor allen dingen
diesem wahlkampf war das eigentlich sehr
gut wir sind rechtzeitig informiert
worden über alle über alle reisen die
der präsident gemacht habe wir konnten
uns auch akkreditieren und wir konnten
dabei sein es ist natürlich schwierig
als ausländisches medium wir sind halt
eben in frankreich nicht das große zdf
sondern wir sind eben ein kleiner
ausländischer fernsehsender in den augen
der franzosen ist natürlich schwierig
den präsidenten dann direkt im interview
zu kriegen ja und genau das ist es eben
wir können überall teilen nehmen wir
können uns auch bei le pen akkreditieren
aber wie gesagt wir haben eben nicht
diese stellung die wir in deutschland
haben und insofern müssen wir schon
manchmal ein bisschen graben um direkt
an die leute dran zu kommen dann sind
wir gespannt auf eure berichterstattung
am sonntagabend vielen dank christel für
den moment und danke dass du bei uns im
stream dabei warst dankeschön und
crystal hat nicht 6 crystal hat nicht
nur für uns jetzt an dieser sendung
teilgenommen sondern er hat auch ein
langes stück dazu gemacht was denn
passieren würde wenn marine le pen
präsidentin würde und das schauen wir
uns gemeinsam an
die anwältin der kleinen leute eine die
zuhört die sorgen ernst nimmt das ist
das image das marine le pen sich gegeben
hat wie eine mutter sagt sie werde sie
das land regierte
mein erster schritt wird es sein die
kaufkraft zu erhöhen ich werde die
mehrwertsteuer auf energie auf benzin
heizöl und strom senken
le pen hat es geschafft ihre partei
salonfähig zu machen sie will ein
frankreich der franzosen ihre position
zur emigration hat sich über die jahre
keinen deut geändert
die archaische und massive einwanderung
erhöht die unsicherheit in unserem land
sie macht aus ihrer bewunderung für
russlands präsident putin keinen hehl
auch wenn sie den ukraine krieg
verurteilt sie will die eu in einen
losen staatenbund umwandeln die
partnerschaft mit deutschland
einschränken sie könnte die eu in eine
existenzkrise bringen weil sie gegen
jede art von gemeinsamer eu politik ist
und gegen jeden fortschritt in brüssel
marine le pen ist die jüngste tochter
von jean marie le pen dem gründer des
for national ein mann der immer wieder
mit antisemitischen ausfällen provoziert
2011 übernimmt sie die parteiführung
vier jahre später bricht sie mit dem
vater
2017 kommt sie in die stichwahl
scheitert aber deutlich danach glaubten
viele marine le pen sei am ende doch mit
einem neuen parteinamen ressentiment
national und einer gemäßigten ton lage
ist sie ihrem ziel scheinbar so nah wie
nie
ich bin wie der phönix aus der asche das
land braucht dringend eine änderung
seiner politischen leitlinien
bei einem sieg le pens würde in
frankreich eine neue zeitrechnung
beginnen
tja und auch in europa aus den eben
genannten gründen wir sagen noch einmal
bus war nach paris diesmal zur autorin
und journalistin tanja kuchenbecker die
seit mehr als 30 jahren in paris lebt
frau kuchenbecker hier ist ein user
nicht glücklich mit unserem titel ich
zitiere flash eeprom der schreibt was
ist das für ein scheiß fremming drei
fragezeichen was droht europa
fragezeichen so haben wir diese sendung
ja genannt frau kuchenbecker wir haben
gerade gesehen was marine le pen vor
hätte mit europa wenn sie präsidentin
würde halten sie das für gerechtfertigt
die sorge vor dem was europa drohen
könnte oder wenn sie vielleicht nicht so
weit gehen zu sagen scheiß fleming aber
würden sie auch sagen moment mal haltet
mal den ball flach so schlimm wird's
schon nicht werden
also ich denke schon dass es sehr
schlimm werden kann nicht indem sie
irgendwelche gesetz verändert
und
für schwierige entscheidungen trifft
sondern einfach indem sie eine art gang
durch die institutionen macht dass sie
sich verbindet mit den anderen
gleichgesinnten in polen in ungarn und
dann einfach auf entscheidungen der eu
zum beispiel blockiert
natürlich auch das deutsch-französische
hält ist was auf jeden fall darunter
leiden wird und damit auch die achse der
motor der ganz europa antreibt ich sehe
das schon sehr kompliziert an eben auch
wenn sie keine gesetze verändern will
manuel marquez ein user sieht es auch so
der hat auch tatsächlich angst vor einer
bedrohung vor einer präsidentin marine
le pen der schreibt um es mal klar zu
sagen wird le pen präsidentin ist die eu
tod der mit abstand größte verlierer
wird deutschland sein und zwar in
unfassbarem ausmaß was würde denn ein
sieg für das deutsch französische
verhältnis bedeuten
also das würde ganz klar die deutsch
französische achse kippen denn sie hat
ja immer sehr große kritik an
deutschland geäußert sie würde zum
beispiel auch die deutsch-französische
oder europäische verteidigungspolitik
nicht weiter betreiben und
ärgert sich immer darüber die deutschen
die über die französische atomkraft er
ziehen also da gibt es einfach
wahnsinnig viele kritikpunkte an
deutschland und sie hat auch immer
gesagt was sie aus eigener erfahrung
auch im parlament und im eu parlament
das eben deutschland seine ideen seine
vorstellungen immer durchsetzt und nun
sagt sie soll eben frankreich seine
vorstellungen durchsetzen
andreas nur fragt über facebook oder
sagt über facebook le pen in
regierungsverantwortung das geht gar
nicht das chaos analog trump wäre dann
vorprogrammiert für wie wahrscheinlich
halten sie es denn dass sie es am ende
wird wir haben die umfrageergebnisse vor
hingehört wir erinnern uns dass den
brics it niemand vorhergesehen hat
donald trump gerade auch schon erwähnt
hat niemand vorhergesagt
rechnen sie mit einem ähnlichen szenario
am sonntag
ich denke mal nicht dass es dazu kommt
wenn es noch gelingt die wähler zu
mobilisieren die hier nicht zur wahl
gehen wollen und auch die die eine anti
makrofront machen wollen ich glaube
schon dass es noch so eine art
front hier gibt gegen marine le pen und
dass die zum tragen kommen wird der
abstand ist aber so wahnsinnig knapp
dass man es einfach nicht sagen kann da
kann einfach in jedem wähler büro fehlen
zwei stimmen dann könnte sie an die
macht kommen also die früchte ist viel
größer hier als 2017 und das ist
sicherlich auch berechtigt weil der
abstand viel größer ist und weil emanuel
makro eben nicht mehr der newcomer ist
auf den viele ihre hoffnung setzen
sondern wie wir eben schon gehört haben
ein präsident der von vielen auch als
präsidentin präsident kritisiert wird
der zu abgehoben ist und nicht mit dem
volk reden kann und marine le pen
dagegen hat diese bürgernähe mit der sie
viele leute einnimmt sie hat dieses ich
kann auf die schulter klopfen was man
bei makro eigentlich nie so richtig sie
da sind große unterschiedlich der böse
persönlichkeit die auch viele leute aus
dem einfachen volk überzeugen könnten
gibt es denn proteste gegen le pen
aktuell
es gibt immer mal wieder proteste und es
gab gerade eben einen kleineren protest
auch noch gegen leben die sind aber viel
weniger geworden als wie sie zb 2017
gesehen haben aber auch deshalb weil sie
bis vor kurzem eigentlich so eine ganz
weiche strategie gefahren hatte also
weniger aggressor aggression und ihre
großen themen von immigration und
sicherheit für sich behalten hat das
kommt jetzt erst in den letzten tagen
wieder zum tragen und wir haben es sogar
bei dem fernsehduell nur wenig am rande
gehört und in zaghaften tönen so wie wir
das von ihr nie hatten also je mehr sie
auf dreht desto mehr kommt natürlich
auch der protest
an der stelle ein kleiner hinweis an die
userin emma peel über youtube wer
antisemitischen bullshit im chat
verbreitet der wird gelöscht das
brauchen wir hier nicht lassen sie das
bitte einfach ich würde gerne auf etwas
eingehen was in le mont erschienen ist
frau kuchenbecker es gab nämlich vor dem
hintergrund dessen dass viele angst
haben vor einer wahl marine le pens
einen aufruf wir können mal kurz hier
auf unser notebook gucken einen aufruf
des deutschen bundeskanzlers zusammen
mit seinem spanischen amtskollegen und
seinem portugiesischen amtskollegen
der so ein bisschen verklausuliert dazu
aufruft le pen nicht zu wählen um eben
keine rechtsextreme kandidatin zu
unterstützen wie kommt so etwas in
frankreich an ist das wird das ernst
genommen oder ist das eher
kontraproduktiv
also ich meine die le pen wähler die
richtigen le pen wähler wird es nur
bestätigen dass sie die richtige
entscheidung getroffen haben weil das
ist genau diese einmischung europas und
der europäer in frankreich die ihnen
nicht passt aber es gibt da einen großen
teil gerade von jungen leuten die
entweder stadt oder den grünen oder den
linken wählern gewählt haben bei denen
könnte das durchaus gut ankommen weil
das natürlich eher junge intellektuelle
sind die auch weltoffen sind und auf
europa setzen
eine letzte frage sie kennen ja marine
le pen sehr gut sie haben sich lange mit
ihr als person auch beschäftigt ich seh
fragt über youtube kann man le pen als
die französische alice weidl bezeichnen
ich glaube das ist ein bisschen zu weit
gehen und das würde auch le pen
lebenslicht ein wenig unter den scheffel
stellen also ich meine sie es einfach so
lange dabei und hat sich da so hoch
gearbeitet und sie hat nun auch eine
richtige partei hinter sich versammelt
sie ist kann man wirklich sagen eine der
stärksten frauen frankreich
ich denke da sollte man sie auch nicht
unterschätzen und sie hat auch diesen
diese strategie so aufgebaut dass sie
ebenso viele wähler an sich ziehen
konnte und das ist ganz klar mit der
person auch mit dieser stärke und dieser
dynamik die sie ausstrahlt von von le
pen verbunden
sagt tanja kuchenbecker autorin und
journalistin heute zugeschaltet aus
paris wo sie seit sehr langem lebt
vielen dank frau kuchenbecker für ihre
einschätzungen und für die beantwortung
der fragen und damit bedanke ich mich
auch im namen des teams bei allen
userinnen und usern fürs fragen stellen
und mitmachen und am sonntagabend ist
die wahl in frankreich und dann wissen
wir mehr vielen dank fürs zuschauen
[Musik]